when you think about strategy you think
about what the opponent's going to do
you have to start thinking like your
opponent your enemy your competitor
whoever you're facing
what do you think is going to be the
direction they're going to take
biden or uh kamala
the democrats i'm a registered
independent you got republicans you got
democrats they want to go back to court
what angle do you think they're going to
take to go pack the court
well they've hinted at that
they'll appoint a blue ribbon commission
probably full of famous scholars and
distinguished politicians
all of them people who are ready to pack
the court and then they'll make some
argument about why the court is not
functioning properly
and they'll say that we can make it much
more efficient
and then this race thing which is just
dreadful you know because
the truth is the human soul is
immaterial
and if it is immaterial then the human
being can be free
and if it's not immaterial it can't be
free
and things that don't have matter don't
have color so
the idea that you would identify the
human being with the color
of the skin that is a specific evil
that was committed by the confederacy
and for that matter adolf hitler
got it so blue ribbon commission court
not functioning properly which by the
way
biden has kind of alluded to it i think
in a 60-minute interview when he said
uh that uh he's gonna bring people from
both sides scholars and educators and
to kind of sit down and say what's the
right thing to do and he says we'll see
what we're gonna do we have some options
and uh we'll see how that'll take place
um
what are some of your biggest concerns
you know there's a lot of
conservatives i speak to you know we've
had people on both sides on to kind of
see what they're saying
but what are some of your biggest
concerns under a biden and a kamala
administration well you know i'm running
an old college it's 176 years old
and in march of this year for two months
and now again for three weeks she says
the operations of the college
have been ceased and you know that
didn't happen in the civil war that
didn't happen in either world war that
didn't happen in the great depression
and it's just the will of one woman and
she's got an
administrative system she's part of one
that reaches up to
washington dc but you know there's
public health offices in every
in every town in america and you can
just see
if the flu gets bad in any year they can
shut down the economy or whatever parts
of it they want
and you know the freedom to assemble and
to speak with one another
is simply fundamental and they have
interfered with that on a massive scale
and is never before
and so you can see and and then the
second thing is why is there not outrage
about that well there is
but it doesn't break into the biggest
media
because uh the media
and the academy the elite universities
uh the big corporations who are heavily
regulated and have reasons to be
beholden to the government
and the government itself and its you
know 23 million state federal and local
employees
there they form a ruling class now and
the rights of ordinary people are you
know that
one of their strategies by the way is to
concentrate political power in the urban
centers
and it's a vast country and the magic
the wonder of the american revolution
was
they intended to unite a great continent
under self-government
at a time when they didn't even know how
big the continent was nobody'd ever been
to the end of it
and so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna concentrate power
among people who live a certain way and
and you know that's not that's maybe
most
people but if most barely most
and then there's just all kinds of
people who are not going to get a say
anymore
is there the possibility of what reagan
said many years ago we're all one
generation away from losing our freedom
is is that is that really something that
applies to where we are today where we
can really dramatically change the face
of america
in one election yeah i've been thinking
that's coming for a long time and now i
think it's here
and you know these things that we've
been talking about right they will
change the structure of the nation
and make it very difficult for ordinary
people to have any
influence on that and here's something
you know the intensity of the political
debate is like the 1850s
uh you know violence in the streets
completely divergent views about the
declaration of independence its meaning
and the constitution
but now there's something new and that
is sort of all of the
establishment all of the people who are
in the best and most privileged places
they're all in agreement with each other
and
you know it's just breathtaking to watch
how
uniform and predictable are the things
that are said in the media and the
things that are said
in the academy and uh you know that's
uh and you know they they and other
things going on this is like 1984 the
novel
uh we're changing history now
uh that's you know history is reality
aristotle says this alone is denied even
to god
to make what has been not to have been
and if you look at that 1619 project
that thing is just
atrocious it's just a complete
distortion of the history of the country
and uh and and that you know and
you know thank god for it here's a
bright spot
some of the best established historians
gordon wood especially
have attacked that thing and so there's
some honest people left in the academy
and one has to pray there'll be more
yeah you're not saying making history
you're saying changing history and how
do you go about changing history
the protagonist in 1984 is a man named
winston winston smith
it's written the novel was written by
george orwell who you know was a
communist for a while and was in a
prison
thinking he was gonna get selected to be
shot
and that concentrates the mind he later
said winston smith's
job his function in that novel is to
rewrite
history as a constant activity and milli
millions of other people do it too and
so he gets there's a little pneumatic
tube and a
and a cartridge drops down and he gives
him instructions and he calls up
any printed publication they're all
digitized now
and he changes it what what it says old
newspaper articles magazine articles
encyclopedias books
they change it to fit with what the
party is said
true today and then they reprint
everything
and so the whole literature of the
society
is flowing by like a river and
that is key in the final interrogation
of
winston smith which happens at the end
of the book when he's under torture
one of the points that has to be
established in his mind to make him
subject himself completely to this
tyranny
is that there's no reality and one of
the proofs of that is
history itself is changeable
history itself is changeable whoever
controls the present controls the past i
mean we've heard that many many times
you know yeah you can by the way what's
funny is i just finished again
animal farm in 1984 to get myself
readjusted to it i read this two weeks
ago
and and just to kind of see how how much
of it's applying to what's going on
today so
you know for me here's here's why
my family escaped iran we went to
germany we came here
we we came here for the idea of america
okay it's the idea of america we've
never met george washington i don't know
thomas jefferson
we don't know adams benjamin rush i
don't know
we've never met we've read about them we
know what they've put together we know
why america
became what it is today but we're here
for the idea and we're protected by a
couple pieces of paper
and if those papers go away larry
this may sound a very strange question
to someone like you
if the idea of america doesn't work
what's option two to america
well that's it uh
from the founders through lincoln one of
the favorite things to say about america
is that it was the last
best hope of mankind on earth and if we
become a despotism
it'll be very hard to imagine where one
could go
and uh you know this is a big place
right
and like we can absorb the cubans and
the people of eastern europe and the
chinese and the vietnamese you know
millions of them
and uh you know my own view is if they
come under the law
and they're freedom-loving people let
them all
in uh but
you know sometimes people talk about new
zealand
that's a tiny little place and you can't
get in there
and so you know in this this
uh this growth of this bureaucratic
form of government you know our
government operates in many respects the
same way as the government of china
operates that's to say they're a bunch
of engineers
they control a lot of power they tell
people what to do in detail
they give you a social score
based on what you post on social media
and what you're overheard to say and
what you print in the press
and what your letters say they open
those sometimes
and then if you get a bad social score
then you can't travel anywhere
and it's hard for you to get a job so
it's a very scientific
kind of control by force
and uh and that's it the scientific part
is what makes it different uh they can
mean
they can hear everything in 1984 there's
a telescreen
and it and it's two-way you have to
watch it you're forbidden to turn it off
and they can watch and listen to you
whenever they want and you never know
when they're doing it
well that's you know the the technology
is here for that now